all right now at this point I look and I
say okay that's how long the journey is
going to take but how does that relate
to uh cost how does that relate to a
cost does anyone want to suggest to me
have a look at these one two three four
lines
where are places that you see hours
leading to cost
okay fantastic these two here and the
clue by the way was there's ours in each
of those right so the longer you drive
for the more you have to pay the driver
for because they're just sitting there
for longer and also there's going to be
more fuel used so therefore ours goes
into both of these right so in fact if I
draw some arrows in here one
and two all right so at the very least I
can say oh If I multiply the total
number of hours by the fuel consumption
rate think about this for a minute right
hours times liters per hour what does
that give you in terms of units forget
about the number
hours
this is actually I should put an H on
the end here
multiply by liters per hour what happens
to the units
the hours will just cancel so you'll
just get some certain number of leaders
that's good because that tells me how
much fuel I'm going to use okay let me
pause there I'm going to give you a
minute to do that on your own but before
you do that I'm also going to suggest
when you do this
by this
again you're just going to get a
straight number of dollars right because
that's just how much you hand to the
driver okay so let me pause for a minute
let me see how far you guys can get sort
of trying to assemble a little bit I've
given you a nudge I'll give you like a
couple of minutes I'll come around and
see what you're up to and then we'll see
how far we get into the question okay
off you go
so where are we at well we said we would
take this total number of hours we
multiply by each of these things let's
just do it one at a time shall we so I'm
going to do the fuel consumption rate
sorry
fuel
I'm not going to write consumption rate
anymore because I'm about to multiply
the rate by how long I'm doing the rate
for okay so it's simply this multiplied
by that so I'm just going to write it
down first let's just do a nice straight
substitution step like
so is that all right okay help me with
some algebra the first bit's easy as I
expand out what do I get with the first
term
starts with a six
great there's not really much to do with
that one and then for the next one oh
isn't this convenient there's a number
50 on the bottom which we talked about
before you've got a thousand divided by
50 and we already discussed that that's
just
20 thank you and then a v squared over V
so that leaves you with V all right now
just pause for a minute just look at
this when you're doing uh this sort of
conversion of all this information of
the question into an answer you like
like one eye on your working and you
always keep a second eye on the
destination where you're headed to right
now when you look at these
this is good isn't it aren't I clearly
headed in the right direction I've got
some stuff over V and then I've got some
stuff times V this is this is good right
we can go one better because this is
fuel
what does c stand for again
cost so actually I don't want fuel I
want to know the cost of the fuel and if
you have a look it's right here isn't it
there's the cost of the fuel it's 50
cents for every single one of these
liters does that make sense so this is
actually liters because it's amount of
fuel so now I'm going to say
um
yeah I'll switch over colors now because
now I'm talking in money terms right
therefore the cost of fuel
I get this from how much fuel I've got
and I multiply that by that fuel rebate
at the top there okay so again just do a
straight substitution it's 0.5 that's my
50 cents rather than talking cents and
dollars let's just talk in dollars
and I'll just do this straight
substitution even though I think you
guys could happily do this all in your
head okay what do I get
you've already got this done it tell us
what we got
fantastic okay
again as I mentioned before you always
keep an eye on this you're like 10v
that's good 3000 on V
I've got part of it but I'm missing a
big chunk right what am I missing
this only is the cost of cost of the
fuel by the way I mentioned this before
before you guys came in but I mentioned
this video even though it seems kind of
frustrating to write words do you see
how useful it is that I've written this
word here because I know I'm missing
part of the cost namely have a look
what's the missing cost
the driver yeah that's right I haven't I
haven't paid the driver at all I've just
covered their fuel costs right so have a
look at this and I'm sorry you guys
don't have the question in front of you
but it said the driver gets 45 dollars
an hour and there's two drivers okay so
therefore I can say
cost of driver or I actually should say
maybe cost of two drivers right what's
that equal to
nine ninety dollars per hour right very
good and what I can do is I can multiply
that by I already know how many hours
it's going to take it's right here right
so then I'll say
um
I should say
it's going to say rate
so the actual cost or maybe I could have
said total cost
is going to be this rate multiplied by
however many hours I took which I've
already dealt with right so I'll just do
again this trade substitution and then
hopefully this is looking really helpful
right because I'm multiplying by
it's the 90. so what do you get
what was your name again sorry Sophie
this is the 90
000 on V and you're like you breathe a
cyber relief because you're like oh that
3000 on V is missing the 90 000 but this
is where it comes from right so I can
now say and actually this part doesn't
matter too much C equals
fuel costs
plus driver costs I'm just combining the
two pieces
what have I got there I wrote it down uh
I'll write the 10v out the front because
that's there where they want it on V
there's the fuel costs I'll even put
brackets around to make it super obvious
90 000 on
get the right number of zeros there on V
is the driver cost and
this part barely needs to be written
because you wouldn't get any marks for
it anyway since they gave it to you but
let's finish it off there
okay are you happy with that you see how
we've assembled it and there's actually
a lot of work just to do that like I
haven't done any calculus yeah I've just
been interpreting the question thank you